>> THE SENATE HAS VOTED TO
PROCEED TO LEGISLATION BEFORE US
IN ORDER TO PRESERVE MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY FOR PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE BETWEEN
THE WHITE HOUSE AND DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES.
>> WE ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THESE PROPOSALS
FOR THE LEADER, THE PRESIDENT,
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, AND
THE LEADER OF THE HOUSE.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING THERE IS A
CHANCE?
THE PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN,
WHICH IS LESS THAN SIX HOURS
AWAY, FIVE HOURS, 20 MINUTES
AWAY, WOULD POSSIBLY BE AVOIDED
IF THEY CONTINUE NEGOTIATING.
THEY COME WITH SOME SOLUTION
THAT WOULD THEN HAVE TO PASS THE
SENATE AND BOUNCE BACK TO THE
HOUSE, GET PAST THAT THEY AND
HEAD TO THE PRESIDENT'S DESK.
WHY DO WE CALL IT A PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN?
AND A LOT OF THE SPENDING BILLS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN PASSED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PIE CHARTS,
79% HAVE A READY BEEN FUNDED.
TALKING ABOUT 39% HERE.
NOT YET IN ACTIVE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT
GET PAID BACK FOR SOME PERIOD OF
TIME, AS YOU TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY, THEY GOT THEIR CHECKS
THIS WEEK.
THERE IS A HOLIDAY COMING UP, SO
THERE IS SOME BUFFER ROOM THERE.
BUT IT'S STILL VERY SERIOUS.
TOM ROGAN, KEVIN TERRY WRITER OF
THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER" FOR AN
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT THE FEDERALIST, DAVID KENNED
KENNEDY.
THEY LEFT AS BOTH OPEN TODAY
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS DIDN'T HAVE
THE VOTES.
THEY MAKE A VOTE, NOW THEY ARE
TALKING.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW IF WHERE
THAT'S GOING TO GO.
>> SOMETHING'S GOING TO GIVE.
THEY CAN EITHER MANEUVER THE
LANGUAGE, IT'S FOR BORDER
SECURITY BUT NOT EXACTLY FOR A
WALL.
MAYBE THEY THROW A LITTLE MONEY
AND TRUMP CAN CLAIM VICTORY.
BUT I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HOLD
THE CARDS HERE.
WHEN -- THE MEETING WAS WITH
SCHUMER.
IT WAS NOT WITH McCONNELL.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING DEMOCRATS ON
BOARD.
I SAW THE LAST PROCEDURAL VOTES,
DOUG JONES, SENATOR FROM
ALABAMA, VOTED TO MOVE FORWARD.
SOME OPPORTUNITY TO GET
DEMOCRATIC VOTES BUT TOUGH TO
GET TO 60.
>> FOR WEST VIRGINIA, THIS IS
WHY CHUCK SCHUMER KEPT REFERRING
TO TODAY NUMEROUS TIMES TALKING
TO PERFORMERS.
THIS IS THE OVAL OFFICE MEETING
BACK ON DECEMBER 11TH.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT I WILL SAY?
YES.
IF WE DO NOT GET WHAT WE WANT
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER, WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH YOU, AND MILITARY,
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO CALL, I
WILL SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
AND I AM PROUD TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT FOR BORDER SECURITY,
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY DO NOT WANT CRIMINALS
AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOTS OF
PROBLEMS AND DRUGS POURING INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
I WILL TAKE THE MANTLE.
I WILL BE THE ONE TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
I'M NOT GOING TO BLAME YOU FOR
IT.
THE LAST TIME YOU SHUT IT DOWN,
IT DIDN'T WORK.
I AM GOING TO SHUT IT DOWN FOR
BORDER.
>> FAST FORWARD TEN DAYS AND
THIS IS TRUMP TODAY, THE
PRESIDENT TODAY, THE DEMOCRATS
NOW OWN THE SHUT DOWN SAYING
BILL HAS PASSED THE HOUSE AND IS
NOW IN THE SENATE.
>> WHAT I THINK IS REALLY
INTERESTING IS WE HAVE NOT
SOLVED A LOT OF OUR IMMIGRATION
PROBLEMS BECAUSE THE INCENTIVE
STRUCTURE HAS NOT BEEN THERE.
BOTH DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
HAVE BENEFITED BY BEING ABLE TO
USE THE ISSUE WITHOUT BEING ABLE
TO SOLVE IT.
WHAT MAKES THIS VERY INTERESTING
IS THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS NO
INCENTIVE TO DO ANYTHING OTHER
THAN WAIT FOR A BILL THAT
PROVIDES MONEY FOR THE BORDER
FENCE.
HE CAN WAIT AS LONG AS HE WANTS
PARTLY BECAUSE WE'VE GOT A
GOVERNMENT AT 75% FUNDED, BUT IF
HE DOES NOT WANT TO PROVIDE
THIS, IT'S A VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM FOR HIM AND HIS
ELECTORAL FUTURE.
HE HAS NO INCENTIVE TO ACCEPT
ANYTHING OTHER THAN MEANINGFUL
BORDER WALL FUNDING.
I THINK WHEN HE LOOKS AT THE
SHUTDOWN, HE VIEWS IT AS
SOMETHING WHERE HE GETS TO TAKE
CREDIT FOR CARING ENOUGH ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY, TO GO TO THIS
POINT, BUT DEMOCRATS, THEY MIGHT
BE PLAYING INTO HIS HANDS BY
GOING INTO IT IF THEY AREN'T
WILLING TO PLAY PRAYER THEY'VE
ALREADY VOTED FOR HIS ORDER WILL
MAKE BOARD OF SECURITY.
>> A WALL IS DIFFERENT.
IT'S SYMBOLIC.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
HORSETRADING HAS TO OCCUR.
SECURITY THAT IS NOT A WALL --
THE PRESIDENT EVEN CHANGED THE
LANGUAGE OF IT.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT SLATS, NOT A
WALL.
>> Bret: HE TWEETED A PICTURE
OF WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE,
SLATS.
>> THERE WILL BE A FUDGING OF
LANGUAGE, SOME MONEY.
TO MOLLIE'S POINT, ONCE THE
SHUTDOWN -- YOU FEEL THE
NEGATIVE COVERAGE HE WANTS TO
SHOW, I'M THE HARD CHARGING.
THE CANDIDATE TRUMP.
THAT WILL MATTER GOING INTO THAT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION YEAR.
WHETHER YOU KNOW IT OR NOT,
WHETHER WE KNOW IT OR NOT, A
MODE OF AMERICANS DID VOTE FOR
HIM THEN.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT BENEFITS,
THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO OPPOSE
BORDER SECURITY FROM A HARD
LAPPED LINE WILL BE NEGATIVE FOR
THEIR CANDIDATES.
THIS MAY FLIP IN HIS FAVOR LATER
ON.
>> Bret: WILL MONITOR THIS
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT AND WE'LL
SEE THE DEVELOPMENTS ON THE
FOX NEWS CHAIN
CHANNEL.
THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS IN
THAT LETTER.
IF YOU READ IT AGAIN, AGAIN,
AGAIN, HE DOES NOT SAY ANYTHING
POSITIVE ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND VERY POINTED LEAVING BECAUSE
OF IDEOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES AND
SPECIFICALLY THAT SYRIAN TROOP
WITHDRAWALS AND AFGHANISTAN
TROOP WITHDRAWALS.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS IS WE LEARNED EIGHT
MONTHS AGO, DONALD TRUMP GAVE
MATTIS SIX MONTHS OUT OF SYRIA.
NOT ONLY DID HE COME UP WITH A
PLAN TO COME OUT OF SYRIA, HE
TOOK THAT PLAN      TIME TO RAMP
TOOK THAT PLAN      TIME TO RAMU
TOOK THAT PLAN      TIME TO RAMI
TOOK THAT PLAN      TIME TO RAMN
SYRIA FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ELECTED PRESIDENT TRUMP TO BE
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND HE
HAS EVERY RIGHT TO HAVE VERY
GOOD DEFENSE SECRETARY AND OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO PROVIDE HIM WITH
GOOD OPTIONS.
IF YOU NEVER HAD ANY INTENTION
OF THE HOLDING THESE POLICIES,
HE PROBABLY SHOULD'VE NOT TAKEN
THE JOB OR REDESIGNED          R
THE JOB OR REDESIGNED          S
THE JOB OR REDESIGNED          G
THE JOB OR REDESIGNED          E
THE JOB OR REDESIGNED          .
>> HOW IT HAPPENED, THE PROCESS
OF THE STORY LEAKING, THAT THIS
WAS STARTING TO HAPPEN.
THEN THE PRESIDENT TWEETING IT
OUT, THE ALLIES AND THE
LAWMAKERS AND THE OVERSIGHT, THE
PENTAGON WERE REALLY IN THE
DARK.
>> YES.
I THINK THE STORY THAT HAS BEEN
TOLD, MATTIS WENT OVER THERE ONE
LAST TIME TO CHANGE THE
PRESIDENT'S MIND ON SYRIA BUT
THEN HAD HIS RESIGNATION LETTER
WRITTEN, SUBMITTED.
WE WERE TALKING IN THE GREEN
ROOM BEFORE, WHO GETS BETTER
PRESS IN WASHINGTON THAN
GENERAL MATTIS?
THAT GUY HAS BEEN GETTING
ACCOLADES FROM DEMOCRATS, FROM
LIBERALS!
I THINK THERE IS THIS PILING ON.
>> BY THE WAY, SOME OF THEM WERE
OPPOSED TO HAVING TROOPS ON THE
GROUND ON SYRIA.
>> FOR SURE.
>> SUDDENLY THEY ARE BEHIND THAT
EFFORT.
>> BECAUSE THERE IS AN
ANTI-TRUMP THING.
THE BROADER QUESTION, WHO
REPLACES MATTIS?
A HUGE QUESTION IN 2019.
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE FOUR
CABINET CONFIRMATION HEARINGS
FOR U.S. AMBASSADOR, DEFENSE,
ATTORNEY GENERAL, INTERIOR!
ALL COMING IN 2019.
>> PROBABLY ALSO WILL HAVE
MUELLER TO DEAL WITH IN THE
BEGINNING OF 2019 AS WELL.
>> INTERESTINGLY LOOKING AT THE
PRESIDENT'S FOREIGN POLICY, HE
HAS THE RIGHT TO HAVE IT DEFENSE
SECRETARY HE WANTS.
WHATEVER WE THINK ABOUT THE
SYRIA DECISION, I DON'T
NECESSARILY BUY MAKE INTO THIS
THAT MATTIS' DEPARTURE MEANS THE
REAL AMERICA FIRST.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CABINET
BALANCE, POMPEO VERY TOUGH ON
IRAN.